nous sommes avec docteur alain hassan ou
un médecin généraliste à johannesbourg
bonsoir merci d'être avec nous sur arte
france l'afrique du sud qui est le pays
africain le plus touché par le commis de
peut-on s'attendre à une explosion de
cas dans les prochains jours avec cette
souche mutante exactement s'attend à une
montée vertigineuse du nombre de cas le
pic dans les jours à venir sera plus
élevé que celui il y a quelques mois les
hôpitaux sont surchargés à présent
beaucoup de vols venant de l'europe de
l'angleterre entre autres ont été
annulés et dans les deux sens est un
roman qu'est ce que vous pouvez nous
dire de cette souche mutante qu'est ce
qui la différencie du coup vite basique
pour le voir ce qu'on peut dire c'est
que c'est beaucoup plus contagieux
nous ne sommes pas sûrs de la virulence
pour le moment on va devoir attendre ce
qui s'y passe c'est que les gens les
personnes plus jeunes sont touchés
qu'auparavant alors les chercheurs
affirment qu'il est différent de la
souche au royaume uni est ce qu'il faut
se préparer à des mutations constantes à
travers le monde du conte vide et
quelles en sont les conséquences
écoutez le nombre de mutations sont des
dizaines de milliers des dizaines de
minutes de mutations jusqu'à présent de
toute façon ne savons pas où cela va
nous mener
on ne peut pas laisser beaucoup plus
violent ou pas mais beaucoup plus
contagieux pour l'homme
tout ce qu'on peut dire et l'avènement
du vaccin oms et on espère que le vaccin
sera efficace
on a testé jusqu'à présent au sens la
population au total l'afrique du sud
compte 10 60 millions d'habitants 10% la
population ont été vaccinés
alors justement est ce qu'il ya une
question qui se pose autour du vaccin
avec cette nouvelle souche c'est ce
qu'il va s'avérer inutile on ne sait pas
aujourd'hui c'est une grande question
que tout le monde se pose
nous ne savons pas alors est-ce que sur
place les sud africains sont inquiets
qu'à quelle mesure le gouvernement va
mettre en place pour en
et cette nouvelle vague qui ce qui va
arriver prochainement arriver nationale
le pays c'est la saison estivale la
plupart grand-dakar population est cela
qu dans le kwazulu natal à biot part aux
quarts la côte le golden lutte
malheureusement ce sont les pointes fait
très chaud il ya des contre feux les
plages sont interdites les bars et
restaurants d'un fermé à 11 heures est
possible des restrictions qui vont être
annoncés dans les jours ou les heures
qui vont tenir les gens portent des
masques
c'est ça les tees les mains et c'était
un terrain mais il faut croire que ce
n'est pas suffisant vous qui est requis
est un âge où en êtes-vous est ce que
vous sentez une inquiétude chez les sud
africains net et utile qui se révèle
encore plus fort qu'avant
certainement les gens se protègent le
plus possible mais vu que c'était juste
très contagieux il ya les lieux prendre
les gens qui se baladent qui ne savent
pas qu'ils sont contaminés consorts ont
pas été testés sont asymptomatiques et
aide à propager le virus ça c'est sûr
comment vous décrire comment vous
expliquez que ce soit le pays d'afrique
le plus touché par l'épidémie
l'afrique du sud écoutez je crois que
c'est parce que c'est il ya le plus de
test et ils ont été performants en
afrique du sud par rapport au reste de
l'afrique
je pense que la raison la plus
compréhensible
il ya un manque de retour des autres
pays africains c'est ça y est on n'a pas
d'information qui se passe dans les pays
étrangers d'autres pays d'afrique à la
campagne à tester tout le monde comme en
europe le tester et payant a comme en
france par exemple quand je crois que ya
beaucoup de gens qui sont positifs ne le
savent pas et souvent asymptomatique
merci beaucoup alors un salut à d'avoir
répondu à nos questions je rappelle que
vous êtes médecin généraliste à
johannesbourg